- What do you think J. Lo does
to get these abs?
- I don't know, but I want to know.
But even if I knew I
probably wouldn't do it.
(upbeat music)
- J. Lo is supposed to
be here later today,
so we're gonna see if
she's into her own abs.
- Does J. Lo know her abs?
- I would.
Here's the thing, we
saw J. Lo for a second.
She looks like a goddess.
She's glowing from a mile away.
- She's in her birthday suit,
and by her birthday suit I mean Versace.
- Yeah, J. Lo was born in Versace.
- Oh she looks good.
- [Molly] She is so amazing.
- [Sam] She has great
abs, don't you think?
- She has great abs.
- J. Lo's getting closer and
we can feel it in the air.
- I can literally feel the heat.
The temperature just went up five degrees.
- J. Lo!
- [Sam] Jenny from the block.
- [Jillian] Gosh her body's amazing.
I'm not gonna lie to you guys.
Underneath this is that exact body.
- Same bod, same bod.
- Same bod.
- We can see J. Lo.
She's up on the platform right now.
- With any luck we'll
be splashed by her sweat
in about five minutes.
- [Ashly] Oh my gosh.
- J. Lo watch 2K15.
How do you think she gets that body?
- I don't know, but I want to ask her.
- I can only see her nose,
and she looks incredible.
- Just her nose looks better
than the rest of my body.
- J. Lo is at least 20 years older
than the average person here
and looks thirty-seven years better.
- That wasn't even a real thing.
- Yes it is, it totally is.
- J. Lo, how cute is she?
- Look at that.
- Oh my God, is it weird
that I'm attracted to my mom? (laughs)
- I mean, if your mom's J. Lo.
- She is beautiful.
- He didn't know his mom's abs.
- His own mom's abs.
- But he was into them which was weird.
- It's all right. It was J. Lo so ...
- If J. Lo was my mom I
would be into her abs, TBH.
Oh my God she looked amazing.
- I'm pregnant right now.
- [Sam] J. Lo!
- [Ashly] Buzzfeed!
J. Lo was walking past ...
- [Sam] There she goes.
- There she J. goes.
- Jesus, J. Lo.
She like Benjamin Buttoned it
as she walked down the carpet.
I think she just got younger.
Oh! There she goes.
Goodbye J. Lo.
J. Lo watch is over.
It's been a minute now and we're
still thinking about J. Lo.
Rest in peace J. Lo's presence.
- I'm gonna take this.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- [Ashly] Bye!
- And there he goes with his mom's abs.
- Ladies and gentlemen
that was Tyler Posey.
(upbeat music)